we heard joe carnahan speak at a film
festival someone asked you know how much
easier is it for you these days then
when you were getting started I said I'm
working harder now than I ever did in my
career so 2004 vs. 2013 Gary King that
saw his friend from junior High's will
be back then versus now what's the
difference of workflow and
yeah it's I just had this discussion
with my friend the other day about the
amount of films I used to watch I you
know I used to watch tons of films I
find a new filmmaker I'd gobble up his
filmography stuff and now I find I have
so little time to actually watch films
you know and I probably you know I
always catch up from the year before
because I have to wait for video like I
go to the theater maybe 10 times a year
and then everything else is Netflix
streaming or renting or buying blu-rays
I still support blu-rays I still buy and
it's something you know it's it's the
time it's a scarcity of time because for
me my philosophy is if if I'm not
working on it then it's not getting done
and then my career is on hold because
I'm the one who has to do it no one is
gonna do it for me
you know I don't have the luxury or the
money to pay someone to edit or produce
my family for my stuff you know so if
I'm chilling in a coffee shop or if I'm
just you know and I don't play video
games so but if I'm doing times about to
say if I played it but I tell if I'm
doing something that's even if it's
casual like distraction to you know pass
the time I'm always thinking about
there's this work that's not getting
done and that's my career on hold
because I'm not doing it so that's the
thing it's the it is it is very busy
because I'm I'm developing right now
like a ten million dollar musical that I
want to do if I can find the money you
know it's a big scope scale where if
someone sees sherman's on if the right
person sees Sherman's song is hey what
do you want to do if I can give you this
amount I want to have that project ready
but I'm also developing you know the
smaller lower budget ones where if I
have to do private investors this time
which I'm getting money now doing it I
have to do it that way and
scaled down different genre not a
musical but something else where this
shot genre is very marketable and
commercial and something that without
star power can still be put out there so
it's you know creating all these
projects ready to go and being able to
have them you know fully developed if
someone asks so that takes a lot of time
do you think being a workaholic is
almost necessary to pass too sir any of
us sustained it seems like everyone we
know that are making a living from their
art and some sense of our workaholics
yeah I don't think I'm a workaholic I
gotta make a call hold on I got no no I
um I it's funny because I don't think I
am but my dad was I think my brother is
and I would say if people asked me
because as much as I want to hang out I
don't hang out all the time with friends
because I just feel like if I'm hanging
I should be working so I guess that is
the definition of or Golic but it's your
passion you really enjoy it so you don't
feel like it's work so that's why what
we call a passion holic or something
it's something it's something else
because it's not I'm not putting on my
hair I'm not you know dragging my feet
doing it something like I can't wait to
do it I can't wait to you know do this
and that diamond and stuff so yeah
you